twice each year the Setting Sun
perfectly aligned with the street grid
of Manhattan something called Manhattan
edge
here's why as the Earth rotates daily on
its axis an observer like me sweeps out
a circular trajectory and it is this
trajectory that defines what we mean by
east and west and also north and south
now if the Earth's rotation axis pointed
straight up and down then the Sun would
always rise due east and set due west
just as many of us were taught in school
but the rotation axis is actually tilted
by about 23 degrees and when it comes to
Manhattanhenge this is key in late June
the northern hemisphere is tilted toward
the Sun and this downward tilt makes the
sun's position when it rises and sets
shift a little northward six months
later in late December the northern
hemisphere points away from the Sun and
this upward tilt makes the sun's
position when it rises and sets shift a
little southward
and so in June I see the sunset north of
due west and in December I see the
sunset south of due west in between from
December to June the Sun sets a little
further north each evening and from June
to December
it sets a little further south each
evening this results in two special days
when the Sun set perfectly aligns with
the cross streets of Manhattan
Manhattanhenge and because of the
particular orientation of the New York
Street grid this occurs in late May and
mid-july near Memorial Day and
baseball's all-star game which inspired
my friend Neil Tyson to quip that our
distant descendants excavating in
ancient Manhattan will conclude that we
chose the grid orientation to honor war
and sports perhaps but I think our
descendants would more likely realize
that any other grid orientation would
have made a drive along Fifth Avenue a
somewhat less effective route for
traversing the city bottom line forget
symbolism just look and marvel
you